well this week President Obama also made
waves with his speech at the National
Prayer Breakfast when he spoke of Isis
and then issued these words of warning
to Christians unless we get on our high
horse and think this is unique to some
other place remember that during the
Crusades in the Inquisition people
committed terrible deeds in the name of
Christ how do you think Jesus would
react I would imagine that Jesus would
be outraged instead of closing
Guantanamo Bay frankly sir you ought to
close your mouth
Barack Obama is comfortable with
extremism we see ISIL brutal vicious
death pulpit in the name of religion
Terri's out unspeakable acts of
barbarism
you see sectarian war in Syria the
murder of Muslims and Christians in
Nigeria religious war in the Central
African Republic a rising tide of
anti-semitism and hate crimes in Europe
the president's messages I read it is
Christians you have no right to judge
Isis you have blood on your hands